quand on est jeune on ne pense pas aux
conséquences
on est invincible
mais avec l'été il y à cette sensation
que tout peut arriver et dans mon cas ce
fut vrai
glisse sans doute c'est mieux des mois
en fait ton père me dit qu'on en connaît
un rayon sur les relier mon grand père
m'a appris comment faites vous pour
avoir tous à la maison
la jaguar la femme
[Musique]
vous savoir prendre des risques quand tu
sentons tout commence vraiment à
s'emballer
c'est là qu'il faut vraiment foncer tu
es donc c'est ça moi selena me suis
enfermé deux
[Musique]
vous êtes mon sauveur
et ça tu le voudrais
mon dieu tu ne dois pas les personnes
garde les cachets je peux pas m'empêcher
de me dire que je vole la jeunesse non
mais tu rigoles c'est la meilleure
déjeuner soit tu ne peux pas été de quoi
il est capable
bien plus tôt avec nos
à une petite amie au moins dauguet
je suis amoureux d'elle fais attention
l'amour te coûtera plus que tu ne le
penses tu quand on est jeune en train
disent pas le côté permanent de nos
décisions
il répondait aussitôt je sais que dans
certaines affaires
j'ai aussi une pression extérieure si tu
as quelque chose à dire je pense être la
bonne personne
on ne pense pas aux conséquences si je
le pouvais vraiment
le frère tu es encore trop jeune
[Musique]